on December 12th alabama voters have a
choice between a Democrat and a
candidate who's passionate about your
Second Amendment rights
strong on border security and completely
focused on serving the good people of
Alabama not like Democrat Doug Jones who
was recently seen spilling his Jamba
Juice at a local mall that won't happen
with judge Roy Moore because he's not
allowed in shopping night Doug Jones is
caught taking up a valuable parking
space at an Alabama high school you
won't catch Roy Moore doing that because
he's banned from more than 37 local high
school and here are some other places
you won't find judge Roy Moore the
changing rooms at Hot Topic the young
adult section of Barnes & Noble at a
backstage meet-and-greet for Harry
Styles hi in Girl Scout cookies at
Jefferson County cheerleading
competitions teen pageants public pools
petting zoo or anywhere on snapchat
in fact Roy Moore is not allowed to do
much of anything except work for you
and more more and I approve this message
with your mother's permission of course
[Music]
you
you